so like what have you and Joe found to
be different over there if anything I I
don't think it's that different when you
look at people talking about it on
LinkedIn like sometimes there's this
misconception that oh I'm going to
instantly start doing the US market it's
gonna be way easier I'm going to win
loads more clients and like yeah you can
triple your fee with each placement you
do but it's still hard it's no easier
and I don't think it's any harder like
if you're not doing something that
stands out and gives hiring managers a
reason to talk to you and genuinely sets
you apart from other recruiters that are
probably just as good as you then
they're not going to talk to you and
there's very few people that actually
have something that's a genuinely unique
talking point
um